okay we're about to mount some strain
gauges on to our specimen this is our
specimen here and these are all the
things we're going to need to do it so
very quickly this is isopropyl alcohol
which will be used to degrease the
specimen we have the M prep neutralizer
the M prep conditioner a we have our
soldering iron with solder we have our
piece of wire our snips our wire
strippers the strain gauges themselves
pair of latex gloves if you choose to
wear them some tweezers some sandpaper a
ruler a pencil the little booklet which
kind of tells you how to do the actual
mounting and we have a em bond 200 glue
and we have some tissues here we also
have cotton swabs and our scotch tape
now let's just do it okay this aluminum
strip is the specimen that's going to
have some strain gauges mounted to it
and you'll notice there's a hole on one
side that's to hang away from the other
side will get clamped to a tabletop with
a c-clamp sort of right here so we would
like to mount the strain gauges
somewhere around here and there's going
to be one mounted on one side and one
on the other side so I will just sort of
very roughly mark out the area somewhere
in that area is going to be where we put
the strain gauge
run continuous yeah you have plans right
among those things that i lo was edited
out ok the first procedure as has
pointed out in this manual which has
been scanned in put on Whitney these are
the instructions on how to mount the
strain gauges the first thing you need
to do is decrease the sample now we're
using isopropyl alcohol as our degreaser
because it's a very safe chemical to
work with acetone might work better but
we have found that the alcohol works
fine
it's important to keep the material
extremely clean so once you clean it off
don't touch it with your fingers your
fingers will leave residual grease
behind and that could play a little
riegelwood havoc on the strain gauge
mountain
the next process is to use the NFF
conditioner a which is in the jar that
has the red the red top and we are going
to surface a braid so I'm just putting a
drop or two of the Empress condition hey
onto the sample and then with a little
bit of this sandpaper you're just going
to rough up the surface and this again
is all due to solve for
better adhesion of the strain gauge
surface
after you have rated it a bit sure you
wipe the surface clean and they also
tell you to not don't wipe it twice with
the same palette just sort of keep
everything as soon as you can
now we're going to just lay out the area
of where we want the strain gauge
mounted now since a c-clamp will go here
I'm going to mount it somewhat up here I
want it right in the center if possible
so here the sample is exactly an inch so
I'm going to lay out the small pencil
line at the half inch mark
and where I put it in terms of from the
ends isn't that important as long as I
have enough room to clamp it so i will
somewhat arbitrarily just gonna just put
it somewhere around here
after we market instructions ask you to
continue to climate the condition or a
with these cotton swabs and again this
is just to get any residue out of the
area where we're going to mount the gage
so after we have mounted or after we
have used the N prep conditioner a
thanks the entire surface now needs to
be neutralized using the M prep
neutralizer solution that has the blue
top and again we'll just drip a few
drops and
we'll get those up with the Primus Mars
run
ok here are in here is a package of
strain gauges this packet contains ten
strain gauges some of them have been
used previously so I should also mention
the back of the this is somewhat
important on the back of the strain
gauge envelope are some important
parameters most importantly the gauge
factor for this particular gauge this
has a 2.1 gauge factor and that will
play into setting up the instrumentation
and getting the correct reading so nope
your gauge factor now these as you could
imagine these strain gauges are made in
a very clean environment and they must
be kept very clean and uncontaminated so
they're really sealed in this packet
each one is in a little plastic folded
up a pizza plastic and whenever you're
working with these you should pretend
you're a surgeon working in a very clean
environment now I'm going to spread this
open
I want to point out because i have seen
students do this even though it might
seem a little weird but there there's a
front side on a back side to the strain
gauge
lift it out with this these tweezers
these are delicate little devices but so
this is a strain gauge the back of the
strain gauge is very dull looking and
it's this side that we're going to mount
on to the sample I've seen students glue
these on backwards and then you can't
solder to them because you see there's
two nice little tabs to solder wires
onto but if you mount it upside down not
going to be able to do it now I'm
putting it back in the little plastic
that it came with and I'm going to pull
some of this tape okay so I have the
tape on here still and I'm now going to
peel the tape back and as I peel the
tape back see if we can capture this
with the camera the strain gauge is
going to come with it which is exactly
what you want to happen and
and see if I can just uncurl this do not
touch the back side of the strain gauge
because it has an absolutely christine
clean surface and we want to keep it as
clean as we can we definitely don't do
not want any dust or any particulate
matter to get behind the strain gauge
I'm now going to place the strain gauge
where I want it to be mounted I can
still see my pencil line and try to
mount the strain gauge as straight as
you can on to the sample okay now maybe
see if I can bring this a little closer
to the camera so that's basically what
you want to do now
the next thing to do is to make sure the
upper part of the tape is really well
adhered to the sample and what we're
going to do next is we're going to peel
back the sample peel back the tape and
we're exposing the strain gauge again
again do not touch it do not put any
dust or particles near it now the next
thing we're going to do is we're taking
out the M bond 200 strain gauge glue now
a lot of the glues have expiration dates
on them these dates are sort of ballpark
dates if you're doing serious testing
for an outside agency and you have to
swear by the results then it would be
inappropriate to use this after the
expiration date but for our purposes in
the lab if it's expired by a little bit
it's not that important just as long as
the stuff still works really now there
are two bottles in here one is a
catalyst this super cool bluish liquid
and this other bottle contains what
basically is crazy glue okay it's a CA
cement so what we have to do next is we
take the catalyst out and you're
supposed to rush it like 20 times
on the rim of the jar to basically make
sure there's virtually no cattle is left
on the brush just a little bit and then
I'm going to come over here and I'm
going to
it's really just remnants of the
catalyst left
I'm going to just make sure little
catalyst is applied to the back side of
that strain gauge and then they tell you
to wait I believe a minute and then we
will apply the m bond 200 okay now once
this glue has sufficiently dried which
is probably about two or three minutes
if if all goes well when we peel off
this tape the strain gauge will be glued
down I recommend keeping the tape upping
like peel off the tape the way I'm doing
it rather than pull it up I think it's
more likely to keep the strain gauge in
its place and I have seen these for
reasons I do not know i have seen the
strain gauges fail to adhere to the
material so if in fact when you peel off
the tape the strain gauge comes with it
then you just have to start completely
from scratch the strain gauge is no good
you have to throw it out and just I
can't really tell you why sometimes it
happens but it does sometimes happen
okay now the next thing for us to do is
to solder two wires to these two little
pads here now it's always a good
practice because as I mentioned the
strain gauges are very delicate we're
going to just cover up
like surgery cover everything except
what we're working on and we're just
keeping the two islands there exposed
for soldering okay so now this is our
soldering iron out to do the strain
gauge soldering you really do have to
have a good tip on the soldering iron
otherwise it will be ruined so this tip
is in fairly good condition there is a
wet sponge at the bottom of the base of
the soldering station which you can use
to clear it clean the tip we also have
one of these tip cleaning trays which
you can dip the tip in make sure the tip
is shiny when you do this next operation
now these strain gauges if you leave the
soldering iron on the strain gauge too
long you'll melt it and ruin it so this
operation has to be done quickly I am my
object here is to create two little
balls of solder on on the middle of each
one of these lands now you must you must
put the soldering iron to the island
first and then bring in the solder but
don't leave it too long otherwise you're
going to melt the strain gauge so you
kind of have to do this quickly but
I'm bouncing it up and down just because
I don't want to keep it on there for too
long and hopefully if you get lucky what
just happened to me will happen to you a
little ball of solder just a perfect
little ball of solder will be left on
that island and make sure the two balls
don't touch each other because you can't
short this out okay
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to take the wire that you
were given and we're going to strip it a
little bit using the stripper here to
just take off a very small amount of the
wire okay and
this is what I've done here this is what
it looks like now and I'm going to now
apply solder to the ends of these wires
now first I'm twisting them around this
is stranded wire so it's nice and
flexible it's very easy to work with
those are the wires twisted and now i'm
going to apply solder to them okay so
we've taken out one of these little
devices called a third hand tool and i
just clipped the wire in there's just so
I can't in the end of this wire so I'm
going to hold the soldering iron
underneath the wire and just touch it
with solder and kind of stroke it on the
top and bottom and I'm going to do it on
this one as well
now it may be subtle there is solder
that actually flow capillary action
between the the small strands of wire
brain solder in and now it's pretty much
ready to be soldered onto the strain
gauge except I'm now going to cut these
very short
i would say i would say something like
an eighth of an inch of wire maybe less
showing and now we will attempt to
solder it onto the strain gauge okay so
if your eyesight isn't as good as as it
should be you might want to try wearing
these magnifying goggles it really does
make this job a lot easier so I'm
putting them on because my eyes have
really not gotten bad over the years and
now if if you're successful at soldering
this properly we are not going to use
any more solder this is now a reflow
technique so we're just going to take
the soldering iron make sure it's clean
wipe it in that sponge and now
if everything goes according to plan I
shouldn't have to do anything but really
touch the wire but maybe i will just so
this is this little orange wire again a
soldering iron has to be really clean
just touch it on top of the little ball
of solder and touch the soldering iron
and you should get everything to me melt
once you get one wire on there you can
play the same game with the other wire
now I'm looking at it through my
magnifying glasses they look it looks
like a really good joint I'm not sure
how well it came out on here that looks
pretty nice now to completely check this
out we're going to take our multimeter
and we will measure the resistance this
these strain gauges and this is also on
the back of the strain gauge box these
strain gauges let's see if we can just
quickly see this on camera they have 120
ohms plus or minus point three percent
of resistance so let's see what it
measures so we are now going to just
make sure we got a good solder
connection on our strain gauges so here
are the ends of the strain gauge wire I
am going to put the multimeter in ohms
and I'm going to touch it with I'm
holding it with my fingers and there is
the reading of 120 120 point 8 ohms that
looks great and make sure we didn't just
short it to the piece itself so measure
the resistance from let's say one wire
to the part and it measures open
circuited and we'll just play the same
game with the other wire and this is
just to make sure that none of the wires
are touching the specimen so everything
looks good remember when holding leads
to an ohmmeter like I'm doing right here
I'm actually measuring the resistance of
my body
with the strain gauge but since my body
is mega ohms and the strain gauge is
only 120 ohms it's not really going to
matter that much okay that's how it's
done good luck